good evening or afternoon i was just
trying to see uh how many of you were
in the u.s
or anywhere else in the world uh my name
is heidi carmen howard and i am a
researcher at the center for research
ethics and bioethics here moopsala
just outside of stockholm in sweden so
it's quarter to nine for me
and today i'll be talking to you about
the ethical aspects of direct to
consumer genetic testing
so i've got a very basic outline for you
today
really going over the topic quite
generally
and so i really encourage you to write
out any questions that you have as i as
i'm talking i won't answer them as i'm
talking because i can't really
multitask that much uh but i will
address some of the q a and also i
have tried to make this talk into 30
minutes but there's so many things to
talk about so to do that i have to just
go over some things quite superficially
so please if you want to talk more about
some things uh we can do that in the q a
okay so first of all a description of
direct consumer genetic testing it's a
um
basic type of commercial offer of dna
testing but instead of being offered to
labs or to healthcare institutions it's
being offered directly to the public to
the general public who are not
necessarily patients right they're
consumers they're people who want
genetic tests but they're not
necessarily sick
and the offer here is um
like i said direct to consumer but
what's also interesting is that the
advertising is direct to consumer
and it's outside the traditional
healthcare system although there are
some um
collaborations now between some
companies and academic institutions and
hospitals but that's new and it'll be
interesting to see how that develops but
in general the companies are
completely outside of the healthcare
system there's variable contact with a
physician so some companies ask
consumers to order a test
via a physician but this is actually
quite new when these companies came on
the scene in 2007 2008
most companies had no
physicians involved and that was the
whole idea is that consumers could go
ahead and just buy the tests from
companies without any uh anybody telling
them they couldn't basically and of
course it's for profit right it's a
for-profit business
so what kind of tests are being sold a
whole bunch of different types of tests
from health related tests or disease
related tests including monogenic and
complex
disorders as well as non-disease related
such as genealogy ancestry
pharmacogenomics paternity
and carrier testing although some people
would put that in the health category so
as you can see there's just a lot
um
and then also there are different
packages or the tests are sold in yeah
in different ways so some companies few
of them
we don't tend to talk about those a lot
but we
we probably should
offer single gene tests and i'll show
you one of these companies in a second
so just one test
in one gene and they talk about they
give you back the results for one
disorder other companies sell multi
tests you know like tens or dozens of
tests where it might be under one
type of disorder so a cardio
package they might call it and they
might test for
you know 12 genes and maybe 24 mutations
something like that or a different
permutation but it's still a small
number then we have genome-wide
tests that are being offered and this is
probably the category that has been
talked about the most in the news
um because one of the
companies most popular common companies
23andme offers this type of testing it's
where they test for hundreds of
thousands to millions of different smps
throughout the whole genome and then
they give back results for many many
phenotypes
over 50 and up to over 200 phenotypes
are are discussed in the results and now
more recently some companies are
offering whole genome sequencing so the
whole genome is sequenced and the
results are given back uh to the
consumer and this is quite new and some
companies are
even offering just raw data no
interpretation so
there's basically a lot of variation in
the companies okay so i'm pointing that
out now because if you're going to
discuss this further if you're going to
read an article um etc you should really
know what kind of
company you're talking about
because especially for the ethical
issues
and regulatory issues uh the details
matter
so this is how it works uh in general
for a consumer that go on the internet
they buy a test
on the internet they would receive a kid
at home and um collect saliva in that
kit send it back to the company or to
the lab the company deals with where the
dna would be extracted
from the saliva
and
the dna would be analyzed and the
results would be returned to the
consumer usually via the internet
and these are examples
of what a consumer could get back so
in your
uh in the the
first column on the left
are phenotypes and they happen to all be
disease phenotypes this is an example
from 23andme
and we're going to go now straight to
the third column where you see risks
they are percentage risks and that would
be the risk of the consumer who had
their dna analyzed
the next column
the fourth one is the average risk to
the population so you can see i think in
this example where the consumer actually
has
all their risks for all these these
diseases happen to be over the uh
average population risk
and so this is an example of how the
results can be returned and they've
actually changed even one company has
changed a bit how they returned them but
they're supposed to be
reader-friendly and to some extent they
are how much
consumers actually understand these
these results and this information is uh
it's a huge concern and we'll talk about
that in a second here's just a different
way a different company navigenics which
actually does not
sell this type of testing anymore but it
gives you an idea of um
of how they would return the testing and
you can see that again they were given
the consumers given their risk
based on the algorithm that the company
used which is also different for
different companies the risk algorithm
and at the average population risk for
any one genotype
okay so uh what are the companies there
are a lot of different companies and
we're not going to spend a lot of time
on this but just to say that um
again lots of differences and this is a
bit outdated it was made by the genetics
and public policy list center it was put
together by them
already in 2011 and you can see 27
companies here you're not meant to read
them
you can but um they had already at that
point started separating the types of
companies that that involved healthcare
professionals and those that didn't so
that was already a trend uh three years
ago although it wasn't when the company
started in 2007-2008
what's more interesting about this list
and it goes on for many pages is across
the top again not for you to read but if
you could just look across the columns
on the top those are the phenotypes and
these are just the a's
okay so a lot of common complex
disorders here
there's alzheimer's in here there's
alcohol flushing syndrome interestingly
there's also als
i think it was only one company who was
offering that this one here anyway so a
lot of different phenotypes and there's
many pages of these phenotypes um so
that gives you an idea of what's out
there and there are many many more we
compiled a list uh myself and colleagues
at the university of louisville in
belgium and in
toulouse in salem in france we had i
think over uh 60
companies and there's many more some
people have lists of 100 it depends on
who you include in that list because if
you include companies that sell ancestry
testing and
and compatibility testing for dating
they do exist um as well as the not just
the mother company but all the little um
how do you call
those some
sub companies which is really one in the
same but they they might function in
different countries then the list can
get can go very high very fast so let's
say there's a lot out there
um so here are some examples of
companies that no longer operate but
they were very uh popular when they were
operating and um
they kind of set the tone so luminogenix
decode me so d code still exists but
their service decode me which was the
direct to consumer part of their company
is not offered anymore
and matagenix uh we were bought by
i forget the name now but it'll come
back to me and they're not selling this
direct consumer service either companies
who continue to sell their services are
gene planet and this is genome-wide
testing by the way this is really
the most um commonly
discussed type of company those selling
uh
testing for hundreds of thousands to a
million snps and then returning many uh
the results from many phenotypes
uh so gene planet uh pathway genomics
and of course 23andme
who you may know no longer in fact sells
their health related uh genome testing
since december when the fda asked them
for
more evidence about the efficacy and the
safety of the of their testing as it was
considered
medical testing so
uh i might not have time to go into that
more at the end there's we're going to
talk about guidelines and regulations
but really quickly so if you you know
i'm not a lawyer and i don't know all
the details about the us but we could
discuss that also a bit more at the end
so this is a company that i love to hate
called graceful earth
and it sells one gene test i don't know
if you can see it and i have um
forgotten now how to point out but it's
the
upper uh
left-hand side
uh it says alzheimer's testing so they
sell one
test for apoe and they return the
results for alzheimer's testing and i
this is one of the first companies i
studied back in 2007 uh it's constant
analysis and i just looked at the site
again before this talk and it was
exactly the same nothing has changed in
it does give information about a boeing
and alzheimer's but really basic basic
information nothing as sophisticated and
this is not an advertisement of course
but as some of the other companies that
i've shown you who really try to educate
the consumers and even with that
education you still have a lot of
concerns which i'll get to
and soon so you can imagine for this
company that just sells one test you
think oh maybe that's better but in fact
there's
barely any information for the consumer
very strict information it's there but
it's very basic and also it's not a very
you know you wonder how much this
company knows about what they're selling
because they're also selling pet hair
analysis
um
and some uh
some
vitamins and supplements so it doesn't
look so serious
um and the quality of this company of
course is questionable
so
again lots of variation okay i don't
know if i've mentioned that enough but a
lot of variations of the companies and
what they sell and how they sell it
so that being said now i'm going to
generalize
what are some of the pros of having
direct consumer genetic companies out
there so these are uh pros that
um
you know not everybody agrees with but
i'm just gonna put them out there as
potential pros so
the companies increase the access or
make the access easier uh
for
genetic testing whether that is a need
the population had to begin with is
another question
um
yes and they can also these companies
being out there can help improve
consumer health that's what they say
themselves they say that
if consumers have their genetic risk
information they will be motivated to
change their lifestyle live healthier
and prevent the development of some
disease other people say that consumers
have a right to the genomic information
no
um and so companies existing and fill
this right fulfill this right another um
idea has been that these companies
democratize genomics unfortunately the
use of this term uh has been a bit
warped in that they don't usually mean
that the consumers have power or any any
real say although one could say that
they have
they vote with with with their money
they vote with what they buy however um
it's not true that consumers necessarily
have more power and if you want to
discuss that a bit more with 23andme uh
who have
tried to
to involve patients or consumers in
their research and they've done
they they've done
they've tried anyway and we can discuss
that but usually democratization of
genomics really just means increased
access that's how most people use it
last two reasons are
ones that i personally believe in um and
they have to do with increasing
awareness and education genetics and
genomics definitely uh with
clinicians and
clinicians non-genetic researchers um
and one would think or hope in the
public in general and i think that would
be a very good thing if we're really
serious about having
genomic medicine in the future then the
education of the public will have to
really um
increase exponentially so if companies
offer this education to them then that
would be very good and i i wonder you
know what if 23andme does for genomics
with steve jobs for personal computers
assuming that we understand how to use
our computers that could potentially be
a really good thing
potentially
and finally it has motivated
stakeholders in genomics and genetics to
really think and to rethink and to get
out of the mold that we had originally
but how we offer genetic testing how we
thought of it how we thought um you know
people should have access to it etc so
it's kind of a revamping and that i
think is a good thing
um i'm going to skip over the rhetoric
about the companies very quick just to
say that's a bit confusing some
companies say you know this is just for
fun i.e you don't need to regulate me
i'm not selling medical information but
on the other side they're telling people
that if they buy the tests um it could
be really useful for their health and it
could prevent disease so the rhetoric of
some companies is is a bit confusing i'm
going to go straight uh to the um
just take home um
ideas of dark consumer genetic testing
and then i'll jump into the lc for the
last 10 minutes so this
these services are really offered
through the internet which makes it
difficult to make it difficult to
regulate um it was it started especially
in the us but it's definitely increasing
throughout europe now and in asia well
that might change in the future i'll get
to that in a second the size of the
market remains unknown but a lot of
companies are not making it and others
that are still in business are
definitely needing a lot of funding
outside of what they're able to make
from their sales
especially true for the companies that
only sell gtc
services and don't actually have testing
services for laboratories or other
other healthcare institutions like
decode let's say but even they uh to
continue so again very heterogeneous
group of companies and offers and types
of tests the role of healthcare
professional varies and and that
that
is very important when you're talking
about uh issues of consent and
counseling and understanding
uh of the consumer
and if you think about it uh although i
think all of you are in the u.s but or
oh i see we're up to 46 now but
a lot of you are in the u.s where you're
allowed to advertise for prescription
drugs but in a lot of other
most companies you're not and in fact if
you look at um
the direct advertisement of genetic
testing to consumers even you know in
the case in which every company involved
a healthcare professional we could still
see some problems and those problems
would be
would be similar to those that we see
with the advertisement of prescription
drugs directly to consumers something to
keep in mind and this last point i'm
going to go i'm not going to explain in
depth although i love to but people seem
to uh confuse the notion of uh direct
consumer genetic testing with
personalized medicine of course they're
related but they're not synonymous and
maybe part of the reason for that is
that
the
another term for direct consumer genetic
testing is personal genomic services or
personal genome testing
um some maybe the word person in there
confuses people but they're definitely
uh separate entities and um related but
separate so something to keep in mind
in the future so some concerns uh i'm
gonna have a lot of them and i could
talk about them for a long time but i
won't i'll keep it short so a bit
superficial get back to me in the
questions and for these list of concerns
because i know a lot of people like
direct consumer genetic testing you have
to keep in mind that these are concerns
uh
that you know live in the minds of some
stakeholders and not another so it's
really you know concern lies in the eyes
of the beholder basically
so this is a list um and i will skip it
right away because we're going to get
down to it so we start with scientific
concerns and i could go through analytic
validity clinical validity and clinical
utility but we're actually just going to
look at the last two because the
analytic validity although it has been
discussed and it was in fact discussed
in the letter from the fda to 23andme um
a lot of a lot many companies are
actually using the same platforms as uh
is being used for research and uh for
diagnostics
in uh healthcare institutions so
this may be true of some companies but
definitely not all
the concerns of analytical movies so i'm
going to and it hasn't really been
discussed as a huge worry so i'm going
to skip it clinical validity has been a
huge discussion basically the idea is
that the association between a variant
and a disorder um
that degree of association how strong
that association is basically gives you
the clinical validity and for complex
traits we know that the association the
clinical validity could be very weak
in other terms if you wish the
penetrance may not be very high although
i don't like to use that with complex
traits but still so with clinical
validity if the association between the
variant and the phenotype is unknown
is very low
or is just uncertain
um giving that information back to a
consumer is is very confusing what does
it mean for them and basically a lot of
the tests that are being given by
companies that being offered by
companies are not being offered in the
clinical setting because they didn't
feel they were valid in this sense and
so there's concern that they should be
offered either to consumers
especially without
proper supervision or genetic counseling
which i will get to in a second clinical
utility is also an issue here the
question is why give a test if there's
no utility to it if there's nothing that
can be done once you get the information
if you get the genetic test result can
you do something actively could you pro
could you
take a medication or or change your
lifestyle so you can make sure that you
don't get a disorder and even if you do
if there is clinical utility there are
two questions one will consumers
change your way of life
eat better exercise etc to not develop a
disorder and number two
did the genetic test really give them
extra information people who are
overweight usually already know they're
overweight people who don't eat well
already know they don't eat well so the
clinical utility of some of these tests
even if it is there is still
debatable
in the larger sense so
yes i'm gonna move on now we could say a
lot more so i already mentioned that
there's a lack or people feel there's a
lack of adequate genetic counseling and
medical supervision
um and as you know genetic counseling is
recommended for
most testing in clinics
both pre and post-testing and here the
idea is that without this counseling
and or medical supervision the consumer
will not understand the results and that
may lead to drastic or two lax measures
so this is a very important part of
genetic testing understanding the
results even understanding if you want
the test to begin with and it's also
considered one of the most expensive
parts of genetic testing
so
it might not be surprising that
companies have not gone there yet but
even if they did hire genetic counselors
you have to wonder about their
impartiality
and even if the genetic counselors are
trained to interpret all of these new uh
genetic tests
so i'm going to move along a bit faster
now but you'll have the slides later on
if you want to look at them
informed consent is an issue here
because the interaction especially with
the physician happens all over the
internet so the question is there enough
information given to consumers so they
know and understand what they're buying
they really understand the risks and the
benefits and do they understand that the
information they get might affect their
family members so this is a huge concern
and of course it relates to testing in
minors and some of the research
activities of these of these companies
which i'll get to very soon i have
another slide that is basically just
there to tell you that we already have
concerns about informed consent with
whole genome sequencing in the clinic
and in research in the academic setting
so you add those concerns to the direct
consumer context and you get a lot more
concerns and um
i could give a talk just about that
uh just something to keep in mind
so the research activities of companies
have also been a concern because they
are using consumer data to
create bio banks
to do research basically and our
questions we we study these
companies to see if they were really
letting the consumers know that their
data was going to be used for uh
research and if they did let them know
if they were really obtaining a proper
informed consent we did this analysis a
while ago already in 2010 enough
companies i think most of which don't uh
don't are not in business anymore but
basically we found that um
many companies only said that they were
doing research in the fine print in the
way way back pages and those companies
that were quite transparent about the
fact they were doing research the way
that the consent was not equal to the
consent that we expect from research
subjects um
in uh in academic research so we have to
wonder there is this double standard
okay is that is that is that okay just
because they're a company they're
allowed to research in a way that we
wouldn't necessarily let them do an
academic genomic research and you know
there's some obvious answers to that
question um
but others that are less obvious because
there really is a blurring here a person
gets on the internet as a consumer and
then somehow becomes a research
participant that that needs to be taken
into consideration
so
it's important these companies be clear
and transparent and obtain proper
consent because if they don't consumers
might um it might undermine public trust
and genetic research and the consumers
or the public might not see the
difference whether it's a company or an
academic institution so i think as
stakeholders in genetics we would not
want that to happen overall
genetic testing and minors is also
concerned because guidelines present
clinical grind lines say that uh for
predictive genetic testing it is only
recommended in minors if there's an
established effective and important
medical treatment
that can be offered and if not it should
be delayed until the uh
the minor is old enough to make an
informed choice
and what happens what's happening now is
that companies these are just some
studies um where we did some empirical
work uh
studying this
they are testing minors and so there is
a double standard we are not uh you're
asking clinicians not to do this yet
we're letting these companies
test minors so is that okay
one of the last uh topics now before
i skip over a couple more slides is the
challenge in healthcare system and some
people don't think of this because
they're thinking well you know
if it's out of pocket let the consumer
do whatever they want to do but if the
consumer buys a test
uh genetic test that they didn't
understand the result of and there's a
lot of results right it's not just one
there's a lot for 23 and me it was over
200 phenotypes that we're giving back
so our results uh for phenotypes so um
if they don't unders if a consumer does
not understand these results and they
decide to do follow-up testing with
their gp
who doesn't necessarily understand the
results either
and and
schedules more follow-up testing this
could potentially overburden the medical
system the health the publicly funded
medical system um and we did a study uh
a survey of uh clinicians in europe and
we saw that although it was not the
majority of clinicians but a good a good
amount of them 44
had had uh patients come to see them
after they had undergone a direct
consumer genetic test so it is happening
and this was already in 2011 so one
could assume that this
might be higher now so i think it's a
very um
a very probable concern for the future
privacy and confidentiality looks a lot
like the concerns here look a lot like
what we see in the clinic how is the
data kept for how long is going to be
kept who will get to see it are the
companies transparent to the consumers
about how this is done uh but there's
other ones that are less obvious and
this is the last one in the list here
and and a little um
he goes with a little uh nature
correspondence there about genetic
testing anonymity of sperm donors under
threat because what we found is that uh
kids conceive through
donor gamete conception
uh have in fact found back their their
their gamete donor
and through the help of some of these uh
companies because some of these
companies uh encourage their consumers
to um to share the genetic data and see
hey are we related et cetera so that's
something that should be known if some
clinics although this varies also in the
world some clinics
like to uh or can
give uh
anonymity or or promise anonymity to
their response donors but it might not
be the case with these companies and and
that should be known if they're going to
be used more and more
okay so control i'm gonna end here um
and basically control
can be done through laws but it can also
just be done through guidelines and also
there's a lot of different things that
can be controlled the labs doing the
tests the way the the tests are offered
through a doctor not to a doctor the way
the tests are advertised and you can
even control the consumers which is what
france did there's a fine um for
consumers who who purchased our consumer
journey testing in france it's a couple
of
thousands of euros i think um not sure
how that will be enforced but it's there
in their law so there's a lot of
guidelines specifically not not
specifically about genetic testing but
specifically about direct to consumer
genetic testing which is which is
interesting if you think about it so
genetic societies have put out their
ideas other medical professional
societies that are non-genetic
uh bioethics committees
so there's a lot of guidelines out there
if you want to know more about that uh
we even have compilations of them on
some of our websites and of course
there's some laws that are already
existing
about either medical services or genetic
services that encompass direct consumer
genetic testing that could encompass
them there's some countries like france
germany and portugal that have banned
direct consumer genetic testing other
countries like the netherlands belgium
and switzerland where things are just
changing where um companies could
possibly um
operate
so
that's all i'm going to say about laws
but do look for the future in europe we
have an ibd regulation that is coming
that could come in a proposal to change
uh the ibd in vitro uh medical
diagnostic directive that was there in
the past and here some proposals are uh
suggesting that advertisement direct
consumer genetic testing advertisement
be completely banned
and that genetic testing should only be
uh provided through a medical um
doctor so this has not gone through yet
uh but it could so stay tuned same thing
with the fda that has cracked down a bit
more on 23andme now and i'm not sure if
it's if it's contacted other companies
but i'm sure that's going to um
pave the way for
for that relationship to either
strengthen or
weaken between the fda and direct
consumer companies so i've actually set
all of my conclusions but i also want to
just remind you
that other
self-testing
tests have uh
you know exist already and they have
been regulated but there was a way to go
ahead responsibly and i hope we can do
that for genetic testing so thank you
and uh 20
couple of seconds for q a so let me take
a look
oh
okay
so it would appear that there are no
questions
or i have not
i don't have access to the questions
and
maybe that's because i went over time
well if you have any questions you can
email me
the organizer is typing in a message to
me now maybe it's got to do with your
questions
or lack thereof
oh so thank you very much for your
attention good night
you